oh well you look great today we're gonna
be blind he's testing some food to see
if we can guess what day Ruby
blindfolded we're gonna be blindfolded
oh I forgot what I signed up for
I'm so scared
okay okay wait what is this nose clamp
oh well you look great right so can you
guys kindly see or smell No
did you say something if she can't hear
oh are you gonna feed us know what is
Handy's voice okay so you guys don't let
me stay here what a booger you always
copy okay and heavy okay this is
definitely an apple okay it's an apple
oh wait you went already
I'm sorry hey home I think it's an apple
yeah all right yeah we're gonna get
field of sweetness at my chopper I can't
taste it how am I supposed to breathe it
eat are the same yeah this is unfair I'm
going with a nice red apple okay I still
think it's great how are you still
eating bad
I'm not sure if that was it Apple but I
tasted apple skin and there's boogers
coming from my goals as I speak
let's get this over with let's try to
Cheers okay wait whoa there's another
Apple oh that was kind of sweet for me I
feel like this is another Apple no it's
a train wreck huh why why why I don't
know I can't breathe it's probably some
sort of vegetable you know I can feel
the boogers jumping to my baloff leg
please don't get a close-up of ya
wait do we have the same thing oh oh we
have our own thing oh boy you know they
said there's only two items so there's
like six stitches so this is must be
like another Apple oh all right
yeah sounds like little punches on the
back of my child
sour quiet what's it doing to you the
Apple is punching a lot good you might
be allergic to apples I bet this is
another Apple okay I'm gonna be wrong
and I'm gonna miss when I see all right
let's do another Cheers
another Apple where are you hold on here
at that time
ah wear blue shoes call no Jesus what is
I just like struggling to breathe as I
feel this one's onion I know it and it
fell is it all day I think you're right
because this is an onion like even
though I could really taste it I felt
like a little stinging as I'm like
that's the onion so the onion making you
cry is it a turnip there's another
target
I gotta stop doing BuzzFeed videos that
make me look at HIV
okay Cheers are good oh yeah where are
you yeah there oh god is it another
onion isn't it it's the Apple again oh
thank God it's an apple Oh like I don't
want to eat an onion or an apple Oh
hallelujah
wow I never used to like apples I dunno
I realize I don't know anything about a
little apples are great they come in
many different colors oh wait so this is
their Apple number three so we have two
more plates of onions left I think
oh oh not everywhere yeah thanks
you know I'd be really pissed if it
wasn't an apple like what else do you
think this could be I don't know but I
feel like people love playing tricks
oh okay
I'm guessing onion on this one no I was
waiting for you son no no we have to
Cheers
where didn't you just eat your zone wait
you just put yours in your mouth and
then you cheers mine I didn't bite it
though I know cow it doesn't count
cheers me I don't know
onion it's the texture yeah and there
sure weird like onion skin that happens
at the inner part of the onion I love
onions but it's raw
I don't know like eating this right now
also don't look at by those people all
right okay I'll get time yeah do
battaglia why Vidalia onion that was
called I guess so you know onions
I know apples hey okay sounds definitely
idea for sure I gotta say I think we're
nailing this Apple or onion challenge
yeah I'm positive
okay I think I'm right here you might
have to just grab it
wait hey am i closer oh I got it I got I
got it oh okay
you know like we're done
wait I want to know for a radon I get
this tell us wait wait wait saw was it
was Apple Apple onion Apple agate onion
you remembered I tell her low I was just
like apple and onion how great would it
be if we were super wrong there's no way
we're wrong I guess Yeah right right
yeah how do we do weirdest high five
what I want and I looked stupid doing
hahaha I know
looks like full snot over here high
spitless out with an iron wait you got
like a little bit on your left I have a
large piece of mine I think fair's fair
he made me get the little straggler guy
I had still right five
[Music]